what are my favorite top five sci-fi
Fighters welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so last week I did a video about the gun
staff from The Last Starfighter because
they're planning a sequel to that movie
and I happen to mention that the gun
style would make my top five list of
favorite sci-fi Fighters
I obviously then immediately got
comments saying well what are the rest
of the list so here we go I'm gonna do a
video now on my top five sci-fi Fighters
and then I'm going to do another video
on my top five Capital ships they're big
boys but for now let's have a look at
the little fellas they're one or two
seater Fighters before I get stuck into
the list I'm just gonna say that an
honorable mention here is the Delta
Flyer from Star Trek I never really
followed the reason why it was built I
don't know a lot about it but it's a
great looking little shuttle and out of
all of the Star Trek little ships that
was easily my favorite but let's get
stuck into the list and number five is
actually the Gunstar from The Last
Starfighter now the main reason why I
really like this fighter other than
it'll look seriously mean is that it is
actually pretty realistic the engines
that point forwards to make it stop are
just as big as the engines pointing
backwards to make it go that's actually
really realistic in space where there's
no air resistance in Star Trek when the
impulse engines fail or the warp engines
break the Enterprise will always fall
out of warp and come to a complete stop
that doesn't make any sense in space if
you're moving in One Direction with
momentum you will just keep going until
you basically hit something so a real
spaceship would need engines just as big
to stop it as they need to make it go
I've always really liked that detail in
the Gunstar as well as all the little
thrusters and the loads and loads of
weapons it has particle beam weapons it
has Photon bolts and it has two laser
guns we also know what happens when
those doors open and they hit the death
Blossom button it's a really cool space
superiority fighter it's really well
designed and well thought out and it is
just one great looking piece of
Machinery if you do like the content by
the way guys please consider hitting the
Subscribe button consider sharing the
video wherever the hell you like him
hitting that like don't hit the down
that doesn't help anybody
also consider becoming a fully
flashlight track and hitting the join
button all these little things they
really help me to keep the channel going
in and then those few little pennies
that basically means the wife will let
me keep doing it in at number four is
actually my favorite from when I was a
kid the Thunder fighter from book
grudges in the 25th Century now the
Thunder fighter or sometimes called the
Starfighter was actually designed
initially it was supposed to be in
Battlestar Galactica the what then
became the Viper a ship that might be
appearing on this list in a minute this
the Thunder fighter was the original
design but Glenna Larson didn't quite
like it for Battlestar Galactica and but
when he then did book Rogers in the 25th
Century dusted off the design and there
we go I love how if this was a real
fighter it has a very small profile it'd
be incredibly difficult to hit I like
what's got nice big engines I like how
it's got wings that it would work within
the atmosphere it doesn't have an FDL
capability but that's not necessary it's
actually got eight laser cannons that
sit in the nose would be really good for
Target marketing on your enemy it's just
a well-forter again design but it's a
beautiful design for me it's probably
the best looking of all the ships on
this list it really is sort of like this
Spitfire for space and at number three
immediately Comes The Mark II Viper for
Battlestar Galactica
now this thing is a flying tank it was
designed to be simplistic it's not a
complicated design it's not a high-tech
design it's three massive engines guns
and a pilot and that's pretty much it
it's kind of like the Lamborghini for
space like a lot of these shows back
then it's an absolutely stunning design
I love how they brought it into the
Ronald D Moore version of Battlestar
Galactica how they had this new
high-tech design that was all sleek and
stuff and these mothballed flying tanks
like I say and that they had to bring
them back I love that they actually kept
an iconic design for a new show this
design is absolutely stunning and it
easily makes my top three and number two
is the Mark II star Fury very similar to
the Gunstar here the reason why I love
this ship not only is because it looks
cool but it is actually designed in a
way that makes sense I love how it's got
the the wide wings and the engines at
the end which would make it incredibly
maneuverable and the guns slung just
underneath the pilot which would be very
good for you know like targeting your
enemy it seems to be a very thought
through and well-designed fighter in
fact some people have argued it's the
most sensible of all the factors of
sci-fi and in fact if you're going to
design and build a short-range fight of
a space designing it like the star Fury
wouldn't be a bad thing now the number
one fighter from all of sci-fi is not
going to be a big shock to a lot of
people and of course it's the t65 X-Wing
the t65 X-Wing is purely iconic things
like the Star Destroyer things like the
Millennium Falcon they were so
beautifully designed that we fell in
love with them and the X-Wing for me is
top of that list it is just stunning and
it looks like it's going a million miles
now and it's Stood Still it is an
absolute like conic design actually
again it kind of makes sense in the way
it's designed how the wings would come
down how they would open up for the more
maneuverability creating a slightly
different thrust Vector I love how the
again the guns are right on the wings
built for the Rebel Alliance but then
goes on to be used for decades why would
you change a design like that if it
ain't broken it has a simple one-man
pilot and a Droid at the back normally
the first thing to get shot 12.5 meters
long armed with four laser cannons and
two torpedo launches this is a
well-armed streamlined simple fighter
it's also capable of FDL and hyperdrive
it is capable of fighting an atmosphere
as well as in space it really is an air
superiority Fighter for the future
so get into the comments guys tell me
what you think of my list of the top
five fighters in sci-fi and do you have
any suggestions of something else what
would your top five be get in there tell
me exactly what you think as always if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification and
if you like the content please consider
hitting the join button and becoming a
fully fled side tracker as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]